in addition to indoor malls spa services
open today a news net reporter Kate
Houston shows us how a spa in the
Northwest area of town is implementing
new safety procedures these spa beds at
miraculous Massage and Facial Spa will
be booked all weekend his clients rushed
to get some relaxation after a stressful
few months after we touched the client
we go ahead and wipe it down esthetician
Ariana Romero is back on the job going
over new safety guidelines for massages
and facials someone will be laying down
on the sheet and then we take off the
sheet for Ariana and the team here will
take the temperature of each client wipe
down everything that the client and
employee touches and sanitize hot towels
clients are asked to wear masks when
entering the spa but will take it off
for services employees will wear one the
entire time I think I first will notice
it because it's I mean it's the first
thing you see when you look at somebody
but I think over time it will all
probably get used to just seeing
everybody with masks and gloves Arianna
tells me they've booked more
appointments now than they thought they
would I'm looking forward to getting a
facial and a massage that includes
longtime customer Carissa Robison who
couldn't wait to get back to a sense of
normalcy and I work in the casino
industry on the strip and so every month
after I get a massage I feel so much
better to help cut down on physical
contact during check-in miraculous
Massage and Facial Spa has developed an
app if a client can't use one the staff
will fill it out for them Kate Houston 8
news now miraculous Massage and Facial
Spa will also require workers to wear
goggles during facials one of the safety
recommendations from the Nevada State
Board of Cosmetology